a whole new generation of moviegoers are
getting introduced to godzilla
everyone knows a little something about
the legendary lizard but fewer are
familiar with his titanic catalog of
films
if you're wondering where you should or
shouldn't get started
here are the best and worst movies in
the history of godzilla
there's a reason the most recent
godzilla headlining film
king of the monsters features the
foursome of godzilla
mothra rodan and king ghidorah and much
of it can be traced back to this
colossal classic
released 10 years after the first
godzilla film in his first appearance
king ghidorah hatches on earth to rain
down destruction with its three heads
two tails and lightning breath mankind's
only hope is a team-up of godzilla
rodin and mothra it's a lot of fun and
the kaiju carnage
is some of the most powerful in the
franchise
godzilla was a massive success upon its
release in 1954
so of course it made sense for toho to
push out a sequel to the film as quickly
as possible
that arrived the following year in the
form of godzilla
raids again and as is the case with a
lot of quickly made sequels
the results are disappointing for one
thing though this is the first film to
feature
monster versus monster combat as
godzilla battles
fellow dinosaur-like creature anguirus
the battles are not
yet what they would later become there's
a lot of shuffling around
much of it an effort to look animalistic
but it's just not as fun as the full-on
wrestling matches that would follow in
future films
the mythology is also a little
underwhelming particularly when you find
out that this godzilla
is actually just another giant
radioactive lizard from the same species
since they killed the original monster
at the end of the first film the film
also suffers technically featuring a
good deal less atmosphere and visual
artistry than its predecessor
all that said godzilla raids again is
still watchable but it's the definition
of a lackluster sequel
the heisei era of godzilla films kicked
off with an attempt to return the
character to its atomic horror roots
with the somewhat divisive the return of
godzilla in 1984
and things remained rather dark with
godzilla
versus biollante in 1989. those are both
solid films
but the heisei period really picked up
steam with its third entry
which managed to maintain a relatively
serious tone
while also developing its own version of
the showa era's throw everything at the
screen approach
the story begins with the notion that
godzilla actually first appeared to
humans as a smaller
less mutated dinosaur version of himself
in 1944
when he saved a group of world war ii
soldiers a group of time travelers from
the future
embark on a mission to stop the dinosaur
from being irradiated
and thus turning into godzilla it turns
out though that their real mission was
to swap the dinosaur out for
three smaller creatures who would then
be irradiated to create
king ghidorah things only get more
convoluted from there but
what all of this essentially builds to
is a battle between
godzilla and mecca king ghidorah a
version of the three-headed monster
that's been mechanically modified by
people from the future
to give it one cybernetic head and a
host of other gadgets
the whole film is a blast but it's worth
it for the final battle alone
for a little while in the middle of the
showa era of godzilla films
toho experimented with broadening the
franchise's appeal
through the introduction of various new
characters at the same time
they were trying to keep budgets low
which unfortunately brings us to
godzilla's son manila there's nothing
inherently wrong with godzilla having
offspring
in fact later films also toyed with this
idea to varying degrees of success
here though the interactions between
godzilla and manila are played with such
a comedic put upon father sensibility
that it starts to grate on you almost
immediately
[Music]
that's not the only problem with the
film though the creatures this time
around
the giant mantises and the giant spider
called humunga
look cool but because they're puppets
instead of men in suits
the fight scenes are rather limited in
terms of intensity
godzilla mothra and king ghidorah giant
monsters all out attack
what a title it's one of the best
introductions you could hope for to a
godzilla film
because it tells you exactly what you're
about to see without spoiling how you're
going to see it
like many other entries in godzilla's
millennium era giant monster's all-out
attack
functions as a direct sequel to the
original 1954 film
ignoring all previous installments that
means this film once again frames
godzilla as a villain hell-bent on
destruction
and once again depicts the first meeting
between godzilla and two of his greatest
co-stars
mothra and king ghidorah in this film
the latter two monsters
as well as baragon in a smaller role are
framed as
guardian monsters who have to be
awakened to save the world from godzilla
and the twists and turns that result
from this mythos helped drive the film
even beyond its fun kaiju battles
the garden monsters are here
they're all here the visual effects are
a little dated today but the clash of
these titans
still remains a sight to behold this
movie is pure monster fun
and proof that sometimes you need to
wipe the slate clean to build something
new within a seemingly immortal
franchise
all monsters attack also known as
godzilla's revenge
is the story of a young boy named ichiro
who dreams of monster island to escape
his lonely bullied life
in his dreams he befriends godzilla's
son manila
and the two deal with their respective
bullies through the power of friendship
hey come on over here
i won't hurt you this isn't necessarily
a bad concept
but the film also leans heavily on
footage of godzilla that's been recycled
from
son of godzilla and ebirah horror of the
deep
among others there's also the problem of
manila who remains annoying despite his
noble quest to overcome his bully
there's nothing necessarily wrong with
the premise but the execution leaves a
lot to be desired
the final film in the heisei period of
godzilla films
had to go out with a bang and while that
could have been just another monster
team-up movie
what we got is one of the most moving
and ambitious films in the entire
franchise
the film hinges on the discovery that
the original oxygen destroyer device
used to kill godzilla in the very first
film
also mutated a group of prehistoric sea
creatures into
giant crustacean monsters which then
merge into one super monster that
basically looks like the devil itself
godzilla vs destroyer has it all
godzilla an
ultimate peril and a monster antagonist
that's both legitimately creepy
and appropriately massive it even
somehow manages to pull off a godzilla
junior plot that really lands
it all culminates in a truly effective
finale that shows us the death and
rebirth of godzilla in a way
no other film has in the 1970s
toho was hoping to create its own giant
hero modeled after the success of the
japanese character
ultraman and held a contest asking
children to design their own hero
the resulting character after plenty of
tweaks by the studio
was the giant robot jet jaguar who was
originally supposed to get his own film
somewhere along the way the jet jaguar
film was merged with a godzilla film
and godzilla vs megalon is the result
godzilla and a giant robot
man in the same movie definitely sounds
like fun but the film itself suffers
from a rushed production process
some of the less impressive monster
designs in the franchise
and a plot that spends more time with
jet jaguar than you end up wanting
the film is also infamous for its
depiction of godzilla executing the most
fundamentally ridiculous dropkick in
movie history
and the monster fights don't really
improve beyond that
yes the very first godzilla movie is
still among the best
and not just because it's where our
favorite giant radioactive lizard
originated
back when his story began godzilla was a
metaphor for post-atomic japanese
anxieties about the future
director ishiro honda leans into that
metaphor with an atmospheric
dreadfield story about a nation haunted
by the specter of something with massive
implications
and destructive potential honda took
particular time to focus in on the
consequences of this giant
monster's destruction and it remains an
absolute classic
more than six decades after its release
yes director roland emmerich's 1998
godzilla film
the first american attempt at a reboot
for the creature gets a lot of hate
thrown its way
people don't like the creature design
they don't like matthew broderick cast
as the scientist poised to take down
godzilla
and sometimes they just don't like the
1990s of it all
ah tell me that's not another parade
despite
all of those reasons though the biggest
problem with emmerich's film
is the frustration that comes from
watching it because if you're really
paying attention you get the sense that
there was almost
maybe possibly a hint of a good movie
lurking
in there somewhere before everything
went wrong there are some interesting
moments in the film
but they aren't enough to carry the film
even as a campy so bad it's good movie
it's just a series of confrontations
with a monster so things can explode for
a few minutes
before the film sets things up for the
next set of explosions
and then it ends after the success of
legendary's godzilla
in 2014 toho decided to reboot its own
godzilla franchise with possibly the
scariest
incarnation of godzilla ever co-directed
by neon genesis evangelion hideaki anno
an attack on titan's sinji higuchi shin
godzilla's kaiju is entirely new
as if the 1954 version never existed the
movie features
sharp satire of the japanese government
as it deals with a creature arising from
the sea
and evolving into an enormous
needle-toothed monstrosity with beady
eyes and a devastating pulse attack that
comes
out of its mouth and spines but this
doesn't qualify as an armed attack and
to be accurate article 76 stipulates by
an aggressor country or equivalent force
not some monster we don't have time to
argue over semantics
godzilla here returns to his roots as a
metaphor for mass disaster
in this case the 2011 earthquake tsunami
and subsequent nuclear meltdown at
fukushima
the population's reactions to godzilla
are realistic
as are the scenes of destruction caused
as he morphs from one hideous form to
the next
the way godzilla is depicted makes it
appear that his existence is one of
excruciating pain
while the government dithers in endless
meetings and scientists
struggle to come up with a way to stop
godzilla he slowly lumbers forward as a
walking metaphor for disaster that could
always strike at any moment
godzilla the planet eater is considered
a disappointing end to an anime trilogy
that began with 2017's godzilla planet
of the monsters
and continued with 2018's godzilla city
on the edge of battle
the main protagonist has a big grudge
against godzilla
and with good reason as godzilla and
other kaiju have emerged on earth and
taken it over
earth has also been visited by not one
but two
alien species who can't manage to defeat
godzilla
foiling their plans to invade the earth
having all fled the rampaging godzilla
on a spaceship the humans and aliens
returned two decades later to find that
not only have twenty thousand years
passed on earth
but that both earth and godzilla have
significantly changed
with godzilla dna present everywhere the
philosophical underpinnings of the
trilogy's end are somewhat downbeat
humanity can best survive if it reverts
to a more primitive lifestyle
issuing technology and submitting to the
will of gods and monsters
both literal and not suffice to say it
all makes for an
unorthodox take on the godzilla story
one that appears not to have resonated
with as many viewers as the monster's
best movies
this chapter of legendary's monster
verse not only ruled the box office
but it also has the second highest
audience score for a godzilla movie
behind godzilla vs destroya
according to rotten tomatoes godzilla vs
kong
promises an epic battle between the
titular kaiju
and delivers with several rounds of
ferocious fighting
as godzilla and kong buy for the right
to be the one true king
to borrow from saturday night lives
stefan this movie has
everything giant monster's brawling a
creepy mech
awesome tech beautiful special effects
easter eggs galore
and mostly irrelevant humans the film is
tons of fun
and in the tradition of many godzilla
films what the human beings are doing
generally takes a back seat to the
spectacle of two of popular culture's
best known beasts wailing on each other
it's no wonder that fans of the genre
and fans of blockbuster action in
general have responded so positively to
it
eberra horror of the deep also known as
godzilla
versus the sea monster and godzilla
ebera
mothra big duel in the south seas begins
the stage of godzilla's showa era
when godzilla gets silly and toho cuts
costs the film features a friendlier
looking godzilla fighting what's
basically a giant lobster
originally conceived as a vehicle for
king kong
the project was retooled when touhou and
rankin bass
which produced a king kong cartoon
couldn't come to terms on kong's use
well not really retooled so much as just
sticking godzilla in where kong would
appear
the movie is a jumble of spy shenanigans
terrorists called the red bamboo
enslaving islanders a damsel in distress
and a criminal who reforms after his
misadventures
godzilla doesn't just fight eberra but
mothra too
as she arrives to save her people all
before the island is
nuked out of existence the movie is slow
paced and it takes a long time for
godzilla to appear
even by godzilla film standards where
other godzilla movies evoke bewilderment
and terror
at the awesome power of nature this
movie has a scene where godzilla and
everett play ping-pong with rock
it's not good check out one of our
newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you